more developments tonight out of georgia
the january 5th runoffs the
extreme socialist democratic senate
candidates doubling down on their far
left fantasies and agenda
that will become reality if republicans
david perdue and kelly loffler are not
re-elected
well the country's calling out to our
friends and georgia we need you
john ossoff ramping up his open borders
plan saying at a recent event
federal agents should be used to ensure
that illegal immigrants are being paid
fair wages
what about enforcing the law immigration
law on the books
meanwhile raphael warnock is continuing
to align himself with the most extreme
far-left members of congress
you know congresswoman omar and to leave
recently participating in a care
fundraiser for warnock
that included far left activists linda
sarsour
a history of virulent anti-semitic
remarks
earlier today barely there biden limped
all the way down to atlanta to try and
drum up support
look at this crowd that's him speaking
wow
it's huge he you know i guess all the
peach state
socialists showed up but there's only
one problem hardly anyone showed up
it's frankly just downright embarrassing
this is the guy that got 15 million more
votes than hillary
and 15 million more than obama i had no
idea he was that popular
parking lot drew just a few cars no
enthusiasm
no energy barely any people and we're
supposed to believe he's the most
popular
democrat of all time yep more popular
than obama and hillary
um maybe he's actually not a lot of
issues facing georgia but also the
country
and by the way uh that's in the latest
ad take a look
i don't know how the heck you stay in
such great shape man
if you look you used to get up and do it
man i tell you
i reached up and grabbed his arm it's as
big as my thigh
not that funny you know what biden
didn't tell you raphael warnock's
radical past and includes louis
farrakhan nation of islam
also comparing israeli prime minister to
george wallace
he will rub her stamp as will jon ossoff
any of chucky schumer's far left agenda
the green new deal
open borders yeah everything's free and
taxes taxes and more taxes and packing
the court and
ending the filibuster joining us now uh
well first we're going to show his
latest campaign ad david perdue showing
us what's at stake in this election
we win these races in georgia so that we
don't have to
negotiate no negotiation think about
that
with john ossoff they get total control
we get police
defunded illegal immigrants voting
your private health insurance taken away
military gutted is that really what you
want
that really what you want georgia
senator david perdue
um i was shocked nobody showed up
he's supposed to be the most popular
political figure of all time
hi sean you know this is the second time
the uh joe biden has come down to
georgia
and not attracted a crowd he came to
warm springs before and he came down
this time and
i mean look we're on a 125
town tour of the state of georgia around
small
towns and we've had bigger crowds in
every single one of these
stops and i mean small towns from hay
highway to hiawassee
than he did today but we want him to
keep coming down because he quietly told
the democrats to coolant on
defunding the police that that's a loser
he said well they
they're denying that they want to defund
the police here we've got two candidates
uh running against one against kelly
leflar one against me that both want to
defund
the police one of them is caught on
video and it abolished the police rally
the other
says that they're gangsters and thugs so
these are two liberal
democrats that we're running against
that what as you just said
will be nothing but rubber stamps for
chuck schumer as he uh perpetrates this
socialist agenda on america
explain specifically what like i could
say to donald trump supporters i could
tell them what's at stake
four years of hard work is at stake uh
which will be ripped apart uh they'll
never stop the never-ending harassment
of the president and his family
and more importantly you know one of the
other issues you see is key because
january 5th
is not exactly on everyone's calendar as
a voting day
no it's not and we have the holiday
season upon us uh so this is an unusual
nine-week runoff but it's very clear you
just have to listen what chuck sumer
said and you've showed it night after
night
take georgia change america you just
heard a clip about aoc not wanting to
compromise and negotiate
and what schumer will do is change the
voting rule to where he can do anything
he wants with 51 votes
and with 50 in the senate and plus the
vice president if they get there
they will have the majority and they'll
add two states four democratic seats
they'll stack the court
they'll absolutely try to change the
electoral college
and this is what i see coming to fund
the police is only the start of it
they want illegal immigrants to vote
stacey abrams just said that a couple
weeks ago
they want us to cut our military again
which is what obama
did and what clinton did but i really
think the
the people of georgia have awakened to
this fraud this absolute hypocrisy the
democrats are trying to perpetrate here
because they won't defend
any of these policies that are in the
democratic platform
we're seeing this all over the state uh
sean we're going around the state and
people are outraged and what we need to
do is make sure they get out and vote
and if they want to help us go to purdue
senate dot com and help us out this is
a fight for our lifetime we're the last
line of defense here in georgia
all right senator i i cannot i mean for
the people of georgia
your country needs you this race his
re-election
kelly laflin's re-election is critical
thank you
sir for being with us we appreciate it